a child in any given moment just needs
to be loved
and when nobody else is there to provide
it someone has to
and it doesn't matter who it is or how
it is
they should be able to have the love
that they deserve
[Applause]
[Music]
i have always wanted to be a foster
parent as long as i can remember from
probably about 12 years old on and my
joy and my passion is children ah you do
match with me
so
for me it just made sense to take care
of children in the community in that way
you know initially
she wanted lots of kids and i wanted
one
little did i know then like i couldn't
fathom that it would grow to what it is
now
[Music]
i don't think that i ever went out
looking to have a multi-racial family
but i don't think
that kids growing up in a multi-racial
household look at their brothers or
sisters as anything different than their
brothers or sisters
the multi-ethnic placement act bars
child welfare agencies adoption agencies
from discriminating on the basis of race
or ethnicity in placing kids for foster
care or adoption
the idea was
kids should not languish in foster care
when there are loving safe homes out
there for them
and
what you had was a situation where there
were a lot of black children in the
foster care system
and caseworkers lawyers
judges were not placing those black kids
in those loving safe homes because their
skin color did not match the skin color
of the parents willing to take them in
and so a group of bipartisan
people in congress
got together and said this is crazy what
these children need are families
and it doesn't matter whether they're
white families or black families or
hispanic families what they need is a
loving safe home
unfortunately the multi-ethnic placement
act is becoming increasingly unpopular
and
i am just amazed at the way these
activists from outside the system are
using the foster care system to advance
an agenda social justice that has
absolutely nothing to do with the needs
of these
children astrid
goes to your breakfast
okay
[Music]
so sarah and nick pendleton have adopted
four children two of the children that
they adopted were african-american and i
cannot figure out why we would care what
nick and sarah's skin color is when it
comes to
their ability to care for these children
i had just had this dream just had about
a little girl with beautiful brown skin
and
heart problems and
when the worker called she said i have a
girl it was like boom i
knew she was my girl and she was like
well i need to tell you about her and i
was like okay
and she said she's really sick
and she's got some heart defects and the
nurse came in and laid a long list of
all the things wrong with her on the
table
and
they were all looking at me like okay
you're gonna walk out too because so
many people had turned down this child
even with a medical background i wasn't
anticipating the level of care that she
would need
but i think over time our family just
kind of evolved into a family that can
handle those
different things when they come up
she was such a part of their family even
though they knew
that her
situation was terminal she would go in
you know wagon places with them
the other kids would get into bed with
her and like talk to her
so ainsley was seven when she finally
died she had been to disney world and
lincoln center she had been caving all
of these things that just they did as a
family together to cement their
relationship with her and it is the kind
of
life that any child deserves and
especially a child who has been through
this kind of trauma
[Music]
as the mom to two black children
i see their race
but i see them
more than any
skin color hair color hair type
i see them
it's heartbreaking to imagine
that either of those
girls would still be without a family
[Music]
astrid does not have any thought about
the fact that she's living with white
parents but she does know that she's
loved and
she has permanency here and she knows
nobody's taking her away from here
one day will she ask me about race
why am i do i have dark skin and you
have white skin
is she sure she's going to ask me about
that
but the one thing she will not ever have
to wonder is
and somebody going to come take me
tonight and move me somewhere else
she'll never have that question
because what it comes down to at the end
of the day is that she's loved and she
has a place
i think what the pendletons have
provided to their children
is so vital and i think
all the time about
how we can find more families like them
and what i see is a system that is
working to push that away
a system that is working to say to nick
you're a racist because
you think skin color doesn't matter
i think that's the opposite of where we
need to be as a country
and i look at the pendletons and i think
they should be leading us in terms of
what we're looking for in foster and
adoptive families and whatever nick
pendleton has to say is so much
more important and so much more
true
than the nonsense that is being spouted
by these activists who don't even
understand what these children need
every every child deserves
the same as the next
period end of story
and whatever it takes to give every
child a family
to give every child an advocate who
thinks they hung the moon and the stars
whether they're going to live whether
they're going to die whether they can
read or write whether they can walk
whether they're even going to blink
their eyes one time on this entire earth
whether they live for one week or the
rest of their parents life
every child deserves to have someone who
thinks that they are the greatest on
this earth
[Music]
you